but uh glad to have a
krishi Sharma to talk this morning and
we want to take up too much time to
introduce her but let her introduce
herself through the topics that she'll
be sharing with us okay
hello
um
hi I'm krishi and I'm here to talk to
you today about a mouthful
and I'll close one of my favorite
packages for machine learning but before
we get into specific specifics of ml
flow I wanted to talk about why it's
important and what it can really provide
us what the value is
and to do that I want to talk about
Trust so this is Elizabeth Holmes I'm
sure many of us recognize her Facebook
she was CEO to the former now biotech
startup thereabouts which sought to
revolutionize the medical industry with
this Innovative bloodstain Plantation
she garnered a ton of enthusiasm and
interest from her community from the
public and from the media and soon was
breaking in a lot of money over all of
the excitement that her tool and her
Innovation from Mr wood
however all of that collapsed when the
trust was lost in her product
it turns out that she didn't have the
metrics to back up her claim and that
her product didn't actually do what it
said it would do there was no
documentation and there was no
scientific reasoning that people could
follow
and that led
to a drop from nine billion dollars
evaluation to zero
so
without having metrics to back up our
experiments and without having a way to
communicate what we've gone through and
how we've come to the final process that
we have
it can be really difficult to retain
that trust and that valuation in our
products
and so building trust is critical to the
success
to retaining that valuation
so now that we know that the real
question is how do you build drugs what
can we do in order to make sure that we
have any documentation that people can
and the first thing is to make sure that
you keep your paper trail from day one
of your experimentation to make sure
that you have all of the metrics all of
the different processes and tools in
place so that people can follow your
train of thought from when you started
to the finished product
the second one is reproducibility this
is to make sure that people can follow
what you've done and be able to validate
your results if somebody can't validate
your results then how can people really
know if those metrics are fake or if
they are irreproducible and you cannot
get them again
and the last one
is transparency so
all projects are a work in progress
especially scientific ones and so how
can we know where you are in that
process what the challenges and
weaknesses are and where you're planning
to go further what's the next iteration
so we've talked about why we need to
build trust and how we build that trust
the rest of the talk is going to be
around what tool can we use to build
that trust
particularly in machine learning
projects
so with machine learning projects there
are three main components the first one
is code so the code relating to the
training Pipeline and data preprocessing
evaluation prediction all of that code
can kind of
lead to a lot of
communication between your team and
quickly
change over the course of a project due
to the experimental nature of machine
learning
the second one is your input data so
this is the raw data that you put into
your training pipeline in order to train
your model and then evaluate on it
that can go through many iterations
depending on what the project is and how
far away your raw data set is from the
clean data set that model needs for
training
and the third one is metric
with machine learning we want to see
what the model performance is and how to
improve that over the course of our
experimentation
so how can we properly keep track of
those metrics in a way that people can
follow along with
how we improved our model over time and
what we did to improve that model
mlflow specifically helps us with the
metric tracking component
component so instead of having to figure
out how you're going to store your
results
you know whether you're going to use a
database whether you've been to somehow
use some other tool within your team or
if you're going to go low-tech and use
Excel whatever it is ml flow actually
helps you by abstracting away all of
that decision making around how to store
the data and instead gives you
defaults that it uses to store those
metrics and
it does this through an artifact storage
that it has that it creates upon startup
so once you initialize mlflow within
your project it will automatically give
you an ml runs directly
this ml runs directory will contain
relevant metadata to your project
and we'll have all kinds of different
artifacts that you're planning on
blogging We Believe organized depending
on how you've named your experiments
and the second one is a database the
default is SQL life but you can actually
plug it into whichever database you want
and you can share it amongst your teams
depending on if you have a server for
that database
the ml bronze artifact storage
looks like this this is like an example
with a nervical so this would be
contained within your project root
directory and you could have things that
are called experiments experiments are
grouping of different trials so if you
have a particular idea on how to improve
model performance you can group it under
maybe an experiment called exploration
and that could be used to kind of
iterate through different
combinations of hyper parameters or
maybe different input data
pre-processing steps whatever it is
and each of the trials in mlflow are
called runs so with mlflow they prefer
to use the word run for each like trial
and experiment to group all of these
runs
and then
below you can see that we have the
mlflow.db which is the sqlite database
that it creates on the startup
the mlflow database contains a lot more
granular data around your model so it
contains any tags if you register your
model all of the parameters that you
choose to log and all of the metrics
in a way that you can quickly query
amongst the tables
so my team has found that particularly
useful whenever we needed to find
really granular level data in our
experimentation
mlflow also comes with a UI so every
time you start up you're a multiple out
project
you get this UI that groups things under
experiments so this experiment has four
different runs
and each of the runs will get be given
its own like user-friendly name when it
was created and how long that run lasted
it'll also have a set of parameters
whatever you've chosen to log in your
python code
and whatever the metrics are that you
purchased a lot
besides those infrastructure components
mlflow also has a CLI that's really easy
to use so a lot of what we're going to
be talking about today is actually using
the python API but if you feel more
comfortable using the CLI it also has a
python or I'm sorry Emma flow also
supports High torch tensorflow open Ai
and llm so the last two are recent
additions but it basically allows you to
log parameters according to the specific
framework you're using and it
automatically picks up
and then it also features both a high
level and low level API the high level
API is if you want to do really generic
basic commands to log your metrics and
parameters and the low level API is if
you want to do more complex tasks such
as create the model registry both of
which we'll talk about
so
I was trying to decide exactly which
features to highlight and the boy that I
really came upon it was you realized
that there was one project that
encapsulated all of the features that I
felt were most important and in some
ways kind of hidden gems and that was on
a project at my company Kung Fu AI the
project was called what we're calling it
project llama for today's talk
um it wasn't actually a project wrongly
but project llama was a year-long
Endeavor in which we were passed with
creating a machine learning model using
radar data
and we wanted to predict debris on
Runway
the taxes the taxes be complex because
the data was very noisy and a lot of it
felt unusable so we weren't exactly sure
how we were going to solve this problem
and how much we needed to do in order to
properly train the model
so we
put a lot of our developers on this
project and got to work
we did a lot of exploration to figure
out how on Earth to clean up the data
and how it would train when we just used
a basic pre-processing and raw data
so we built up our training Pipeline and
we decided to use mlflow to start
logging things
we've used mlflow in the past so we
started using it the same way we've
always used it
for those of you who haven't used ml
flow before
mlflow basically has these functions
within python so log param will allow
you to log parameters
on Metric will allow you to log metrics
and each time you want to log something
you can put one line in your python code
to log it you can also log multiple
things at once it just depends on how
you want to structure your code base
so for our project we've had all of
these different logging lines and
because we're in the exploratory part of
the project each of our developers have
checked out a different branch and we're
logging different things and all of a
sudden our mlflow database kind of
started feeling like a mess
so we had to figure out how to make
something that was really chaotic with
logging into something that was a little
bit easier and that's what we came
across hidden gen number one
logging function
so Emma flow as custom blogging which is
what I showed earlier but it's Auto
logging function is super helpful
because it allows you to automatically
grab all of the parameters and metrics
that you want to log
um and it'll put it for it put it'll put
it in the database for you
so rather than having to come up with
all the different parameters and list
them out manually
you can just use this mlflow.autolog
within your python code and it'll detect
which framework you're using under the
hood and then grab the relevant
parameters according
so we found that with using this one
line we were able to have consistent
logging across all of our branches
throughout this experimental phase of
our project
it's made logging a lot more thorough
while having less lines of code related
to the logging which helped with the
technical test
as we progressed within the project we
went from having the exploratory phase
more into developing the actual training
pipeline
so
now we're kind of working on how to
fine-tune our model and find the best
model performance and metrics in order
to kind of close off the project and
deliver it to the client
to do that we all of us were working on
the training Pipeline and you know
testing out different hyper parameters
and it seemed a little bit
like maybe we wouldn't get the primary
or the metrics that we wanted
until one day one of our developers came
across a really great
combination
and we were able to and she had to
reached her training pipeline in a way
that we were able to get a really good
performance
and this was really awesome because we
felt like we were much closer to
finishing the project than we had
originally anticipated
the developer later left our team
and within the next few weeks we wanted
to validate all of the work that she had
done and also all the work that we have
done in order to make sure that we truly
had
a model that we could deliver
however she didn't really leave much
documentation and we didn't have much of
a documentation process in place besides
mlflow so while we had all of the
metrics documented within our UI and our
database that mlflow had created for us
we didn't have a good way to tie back
those metrics to the code
it kind of felt like searching for a
needle in a haystack when it came to
finding the combination of
code and metrics that she had used
we didn't know which permit contained
all of the work that she had created or
if she had even committed her work at
all we didn't know which branch to look
in so it took us around a week of
searching in order to try to piece
together the training pipeline code and
we were never able to fully reproduce
the results
that became super problematic because if
you don't have reproducibility and you
don't have true trust Within
and that's when we realized that while
mlflow was amazing for tracking metrics
what we really also wanted it to do was
to somehow tie those metrics to the
piece of code that had generated those
metrics
and that's when we spent a lot of time
looking through ml plus documentation
tried to figure out if they were already
doing this under the hood for us
and it turns out that they kind of work
so hidden jump number two
became ml flows tagging system that
automatically captures metadata related
to your code base
this up here is a key that you can use
within the tag that you want to set
and it will automatically capture the
git commit that is related to the ml
flow run that you've just executed
so all you have to do is
do mlflow.set tag and use this as your
tag and what you will get is
a new column in your mlflow UI that has
all the tags that you decided to log
so now we see that we have a git commit
hash
time and our team also likes to use the
Run ID instead of the Run name
but now you have a one-to-one matching
between the get commit that was used to
generate generate the mlflow run or run
ID
this made it a lot easier for us to then
figure out how to go back and validate
our code you didn't have to go and
communicate through slack or search
through our git history or talk to each
other about how to maybe piece together
the code for validation
but we also realized that it would only
work if we were properly committing to
our Repository
if you only made commits every so often
then your commit wouldn't necessarily
encapsulate all the changes that you had
made before kicking off a series of ml
flow runs or an experiment
and so we wanted to figure out how we
could remind our developers on our team
while they were quickly iterating over
the machine learning code to also
remember every once in a while before
they executed their ml flow
experiment to commit all the changes
and the way we did that was actually
through a shell script which reminded
developers to commit every time before
kicking off any training job
and so
they would be reminded that they had
changes within their working tree and
that they should commit them just so
that they would have a clean working
chain and therefore commit that
completely represented all their changes
and we've been using that for a little
while and it's actually really helped
and made it a lot easier to tie back to
code to metrics
so we found that we have a lot less Dev
time wasted searching for the code and
we had better alignment between the
training pipeline code and the model
performance
so
now that we had a model in place
and we had actually validated that model
it was coming to the end of the
experiment
and we were getting ready for deployment
all we had to do was clean a few things
up
and
anybody who has done production facing
projects I'm sure will understand but
this part is a lot easier said than done
and for us that was particularly true
because we found that it was hard to
package up our model with all of these
ml glow runs that we couldn't really
figure out how to properly document and
display it to our end
client and so that brings us to the
third come up flow of ninja
we really wanted to figure out a way
that we could kind of highlight the most
important runs
when we were coming up with our
documentation and presenting it to our
customer
we wanted to do something kind of like
in you know code where you could tag a
particularly important git commit you
could say like hey this is related to an
important change
almost like versioning our model
and
it turns out that mlflow has a model
registry and you can register your model
using the model registry
so this will keep track of the important
Milestones that you've hit over the
course of your ml4 project whenever you
decide to put this command in your code
and all you have to do is give a name
for your ml flow model
and the Run ID associated with the model
that you're trying to log
and it'll log that model within this new
window
that looks like this so your mlflow
registry will contain
the different versions and every time
you give a new run ID with the same
model name it'll bump up the versions
for you
and it will also keep track of the stage
of the model
you can control the stage of the model
either through the python code or the
CLI
but
as you can see here for project one now
we have four different versions and the
one that's in production is version two
we can then go ahead and go back and tie
the version back to the running bead so
that way we could show the client
exactly how the model performed over
these different versions and how we got
to the version that we got to
so this made documentation around
Milestones a lot easier because now we
weren't just giving them a whole
database of a thousand different
funds and we're giving them only the few
runs that made sense the ones that
actually captured the highlights of the
story of our Europe project
so this made it a lot easier it also
made it a lot easier for us when the
client came back and wanted to work with
us more on this project because now we
had better searchability over a multiple
flow runs
all of these changes that we implemented
saved us a ton of development time
because we were searching a lot less
through our code and we were having to
do a lot less
clean up around America because we're
doing it throughout the project using
these different commands
and also built more confidence in our
metrics because we had a more robust
validation system due to the fact that
we've had a better picture around what
the code was that was used to generate
each of these metrics the metrics
weren't just standalone
and overall it instilled trust in our
process both internally on our team and
also externally with the client so it
made it a lot easier for us to gain our
trust and have them work with us again
these are some additional tips that we
learned when working on Project llama
and the first one is to block back up
your mlflow database
this one may seem kind of obvious but I
have to put the obvious in there because
it sometimes happens
we were working on Project llama Midway
when our database for mlflow was deleted
I don't know how it happened but out of
many developers it just happened one day
and therefore all of our run history
went away with it and that meant that it
was a lot harder to document that part
of the process because now we have to go
reproduce those results it also took up
some time because now we had to go
figure out exactly where we left off in
our experimentation
so just make up to make sure to back up
your data flow or your database
the second one is to commit frequently
so like we talked about before
when they get to Montage it's most
useful when it captures the actual state
of the code at the time of the mlflow
Run
um so I would just recommend having some
kind of Safeguard to kind of remind your
teammates or yourself to commit before
you run a big training job where you're
planning on sweeping through a lot of
hyper parameters and probably making
some important changes that you would
you might want to go back and validate
later
and the third one is to version your
data this project was pretty complex and
we had a pretty big data free processing
part of our project so that means that
you could have different versions of
your data that you might need to use
within your trading Pipeline and so
having a version of your data will mean
that you have better alignment
you can use the code in your metrics but
also the exact version of data that was
so you can use mlflow's artifact logging
you have a smaller data set or a
different tool like DBC
I would just recommend using something
overall mlflow helps build trust within
your process and your metrics because it
gives you a way to cleanly document your
milestone
and make sure that you all of your
teammates are on track with where you're
at in your experimentation and that your
client under or your current customer
understands where the model performance
came from
so I have a GitHub repo that kind of
goes through all of the
um
ml flow hidden jumps that we talked
about today so feel free to copy down
the tiny URL that takes you to that info
um it is within a containerized
application so it's already dockerized
and has mlflow and all those commands
within a working
dummy model
the second one is my contact
and the third one is kung fu AI which is
a company that I work with
first so if you want to learn more come
and talk to me about it
otherwise
um for questions
yeah
I wonder how do you think they can
apparently and all broken families and
also like way inside
um
and also
oh yeah the last part is like have you
considered using just get to um tie your
code data and model together in one
place
um okay so I think your first question
was
have we considered Alternatives like
like ways and biases and
did you mention the DVD yeah we have to
use PVC in the past and DBC is a great
tool it's more of a CLI
um and we found that it was a little bit
difficult for our developers to really
adopt for some reason you know I think
that it works a lot like GIF which was
great but it requires you to have cloud
storage set up from the beginning and
it's on the garden projects we were in
experimental phase and we didn't always
have like somewhere to store it and I
think that we just wanted to find a way
to kind of use everything within just
one package so I'm all forward
and weights and biases is
um
an alternative to mlflow that we have
used on like the drug abuse projects we
mostly tend to use an offload because
it's open source and breathe and that
part is really awesome and it has the
functionality that we need um
more functionality around like
visualizations but we've actually been
able to kind of
do what we needed to with MLB without
having to
wait until I can't remember your last
question yeah the last question is like
have you considered like using skip to
Version Control all links the three
components of data analog
yeah so
we have used get two version our code
and our data we just use
um
like a basic nomenclature to kind of
figure out our data what stage it's in
like whether it's like the raw data or
pre-processed data whether it's the
final process data so we've used git
especially when the data set is small
enough
um that is a great tool but for like the
actual metrics itself
the reason that we wanted to use
something like ml flow is because it
provides more like visibility
easily with the dashboard component and
it provides easier searchability you
don't have to go and create the schema
for your database and figure out how to
like relate the tables or all that like
infrastructure underneath and
it also
comes with functionality for free
whereas like if we were just tracking
the metrics on our own
I mean we have to go and figure out like
are we going to use Excel are we going
to go export it to a CSV and stuff like
that and that came a little messy with
the projects that we used prior to
implementing at home flow so this was
kind of an easier way and it also
allowed people outside of the
engineering team to understand those
metrics because a dashboard is easier to
understand them like
who would want to know the metrics but
may not have that kind of like
understanding of some of the tools that
the engineering team uses
that makes sense
um
[Music]
so I actually had a very similar
question and I think I could actually
um we had a specific
period time where we were trying to use
DBC
um but we have a lot of sensitive data
and we need to be able to
um locate that data like on a moments
notice so because DBC is more file based
we didn't have this kind of lineage in
governance that you might find in
something like mlflow
oh that's really cool
any other questions
thanks oh great talk uh on the
reproducibility issue you know obviously
you learned some of the some of that the
hard way and things thanks for sharing
so maybe some of the rest of us don't
have to
um I wonder given
um you know your ability to record that
what is then the process of reproducing
and how how manual or automatic is it
and
is it sort of a one-time thing you do
right before you released production or
you know is there some continuous
process that sort of you know much like
testing sort of says you know don't
rerun everything we've done in the past
but maybe you know some of the top
performing ones run them every night or
once a week and make sure they're still
working properly and getting the results
we expect
that's a great question
um
so our validation process before using
this new ml flow
you know trick that we learned was to
basically go and right before the
project that blind because our projects
are not typically a year they're shorter
um so this one was a little bit of an
anomaly but right before the project was
going into production to make sure that
we ran validation and so the way we
would do that is actually through this
like communicating with each other like
Okay so we've seen ml flow this is our
Top Model performance
let's go and use those type of
parameters and use whatever's in our
main branch and see if that will
reproduce our results
um and the reason that that didn't
necessarily always work on a longer term
project like project llama was because
we wanted to run validation a few more
times in between
the process of a year and so every time
we would have kind of like a
you know discussion with the client
right right before that we would want to
run validation to make sure that
whatever we're presenting made sense so
that was kind of how we anchored when
user and validation was based on like
kind of the quarterly meetings that
we've had and with this new trip once
we've learned just how hard it can be to
piece together the code if you don't
have like the most perfect get flow
during your highly experimental phase of
your modeling process
um with this new thing that we started
right before we were going to meet with
the client we would take that gift from
it hash and somebody would be possible
trying to make sure that they can
reproduced
if that makes sense
thank you
so thank you for the talk a question on
the auto logging portion that you
covered I'm assuming that it goes
through the model that you're using that
tracks anything within the um and
finally using this throw it into the
model uh we'll auto lock and catch
anything outside of that or to get them
still logged back to manually yourself
if it's outside of the frame do you have
a specific
so
um maybe you wanna so you make a
computer metrics right you may not throw
those into the model but maybe an
evaluator but you may also have some
metadata that you're not going to want
to for you know privacy reasons or
personal reasons that you want to
attract that's not going into the model
that you want to name the particular
thing
um like what you have to manually say
you want to log those would get the
function or the auto logging attention
anything you have the variable within
the model that's a good question um
it works within the defaults of whatever
the framework it is
or not
within that framework like that or maybe
sensitive
but it does have a lot of metadata under
the hood that it collects it also
doesn't automatically just render those
legit commit hash is an example of
something that it is collecting
Underwood and it has the ability to
track but it auto log doesn't
automatically just show you the game
so I guess that also would apply that
you haven't seen this area where you
would need to lock something that melts
a lot of it hasn't captured them
by your response that you have not
encountered a scenario where you wanted
to log something that ml flow wasn't
already
projects okay
okay thank you
any questions
see what
the one to ask word I'm also does it
provide any mechanism to do like
blogging after you've like shipped your
ammo model assuming that like you're
bringing these into production
um and it even uh workflows there
actually yeah so it does allow you to
log your model checkpoints and it'll
save those as like files within your
artifact storage and you can
um basically use so you can push those
models checkpoints to production we
don't have I don't have any experience
with that portion we don't use that part
but they have like a program
documentation so they definitely do it
do you know if uh like I don't know if
you've worked with this before but like
you know of like people would use this
to like retrain models uh with like
production data as well
with production data I mean I think you
definitely could I don't know if people
use it like that I don't think it's as
common application all the experiences
those questions
look thank you so much
[Applause]